wait for like two tracks
I'll be back I need a bashment and a
slow jam I'm just gonna say my goodbyes
yeah
[Music]
so as you know guys we go straight into
it question of the week and this week
guys we asked what's the worst thing you
found on your friends or Partners or
someone's phone part two and as you
already know guys the responses were
juicy and as per usual gyms gyms gyms
Jimmy
oh okay
Jim's
I'm gonna say James and Jimmy at the
same time cool I said gyms I meant to
start the whole show again
oh that is jokes that is actually jokes
but as I was saying guys uh worst thing
you found on someone's phone part two
responses to Juicy I'm just gonna reel
them off quick and fast
a stripper shooting breast milk into his
friend's mouth no
screenshots of my conversation from my
phone to the group chat
that's that's that's scary that's scary
stuff group chat
butter please no a sex tape that was
five minutes long and mostly with just
him trying to get it up
nah she found that on his phone
a five minute sextape and he's just
there he's just trying to get home off
trying to get hard oh my God out of
questions fam why did you keep this
embarrassing I wouldn't even I would
have stopped recording time ago
let's bang for a couple minutes and then
I'll put it on yeah cause I'm hard I'm
good I mean I'm involved but the
beginning the intro no no no no stop all
that I hate that like quick tangent I
hate that wanna watch like when I'm
watching porn and stuff yeah and you
could just see the Bro his brother's
getting slopped off for a few minutes
and then she takes her mouth off of it
and the things just and he plays that
cause you're not and you're like oh the
that's so brutal supporting that's so
brutal yeah yeah oh we've all been there
every guy's been there every guy has
been there it's like the thing I showed
you in um Nando's
um
pause
remember I showed you that John Bernthal
I was like no no no no no no
[Music]
horrible anyway back to it uh worst
thing you found on someone's phone part
two
on my girl's phone screenshots of nudes
I've sent other girls
tough he's in trouble
he's been ratting him out he's in
trouble James look what your man is up
to he's sending nudes to jail he's
sending me [ __ ]
I don't want to see it again and he's
not even been informed by his girl he's
gotten his girl's phone to see and be
like oh [ __ ] I'm in trouble
oh [ __ ] I need to be my best you know
and she said nothing he's not said pimp
I don't think you understand what that
would do to my chest oh the level of
fear I feel mine wouldn't even be fear
mine would be like humiliation
I'm taking the piss out of my girl
regular degula
she's getting all the evidence sent and
she hasn't said a word she just wants to
crack on
that's tough that is tough yeah nudes
yeah the next things yeah
and then all that big man keep your man
in check I don't want to see his [ __ ]
again get him to stop tell him to stop
I won't tell you again but tell him to
stop
because this is getting disrespectful
now darling trust me um this is the
fourth one I've sent you this week fam
it needs to end it needs to end today it
ends now
it ends right now
a vid of my boy pushing tank fastics out
of his bum into a girl's mouth James Bro
[ __ ] what did I just read what did I
just read cause and I wrote this down
you know what did I just read from
pushing them out into her mouth good
Lord good Lord am I not to push them in
first before that ax could even take
place
they're fizzy
they're fizzy she she licked it clean oh
she licked it please hang faster they're
about about it they're about it about it
recorded hey why are we recording this
bro there's certain things that are just
for us yeah that should never I never
want to see this back me [ __ ]
timefastics into your mouth needs to be
between us
it can't leave this yard it can't go
when the cloud not him [ __ ]
[ __ ] I found messages between my husband
and another man who sucked him off twice
yo bro it's that twice thing that would
have been like nah the first time I
might have been accepting that but twice
my husband got sucked off by a bloke
twice the same bloke
and they're just texting about it
they're just texting about it Bravo
how if you're infuriating is the word a
pic of my best friend on her knees with
nut all over her face my boyfriend took
her virginity
told me she wasn't linking anyone but I
found a sex tape of her BDS I found a
sex tape of her on a BDSM swing
and she told me she's not linking
anybody and she's on a swing she's on a
leathered up leathered up gag him out
yeah yeah yeah fam I'm not linking
anything I'm not linking a single soul
but you
but on the weekends I act different yeah
I freak up I freak up on the weekend
Monday to Friday I'm yours I'm gonna
swing
oh God this would traumatize me a video
of my mum twerking for my dad
I promise you right now
that's not anything anyone ever wants to
see that would traumatize me feed off my
mom twerking from my dad
I was gonna but
that's not me and Mickey yeah
[Laughter]
pop it
hilarious oh that's hilarious hilarious
your dad is in there doing it Thug
just leg spread leg spread
shake that [ __ ]
shake that [ __ ] where's the camera where
is the camera it's a tripod it must have
been a tripod thing 100
ah camcorder teeth oh facts oh God it's
1080. oh God
I found out my boyfriend got another
girl pregnant
tough that is horrible a mass order of
Viagra and dildos she's a Dominatrix and
I'm scared
a mass order Viagra and dildos
messages to an escort inquiring about
the cost of 15 minutes bareback anal
[Laughter]
so specific very [ __ ] specific first
time Texan escorts very [ __ ] specific
wow bareback anal
escort that's he's risking his life
is risk and you're bringing that [ __ ]
home he's risking his life that's shitty
tool is coming back in his house I don't
think so I definitely don't think so try
to catch my dad cheating on my mum I
need to find a pic of him tea bagging
her instead
do you remember
um I'm just imagining the pick I'm sorry
holding this is holding the phone phones
in his mouth
whoever said that would have been
swinging
a pickle tea bag in your mom instead no
what are you gonna say I was gonna say
do you remember that episode of F is for
family whether you was hiding under the
bed and then the dad banged the month
and he's born
his boss was slamming her [ __ ]
wow bro
I can't imagine he was traumatized James
that's ruined his whole life his balls
were clapping boy it was dread
[ __ ] was the name Susan I can't remember
I think oh Susan yeah
oh [ __ ] sake bro oh he's nice
oh God my mate found grinder on her mind
on her Man's phone he said it was to
sell drugs
that's an alibi by the way that's an
alibi I'm wanting to sell drugs
get off my case
[ __ ] everyone needs it every an easy
easy it's easy It's Easy Link in a
discreet thing and it's a boom boom boom
boom transaction bat and I'm done so why
is your profile picture your little [ __ ]
guys
just long length
a signed contract on my ex's phone to
say he's happy to be a sighting to
someone else
I don't even know where these men are
dropping up these contracts signed
contract
I'm happy this is a bread a bread happy
to be a side thing for someone else
nuts
tick tocks that he made after we split
up I'm safe
that's the worst one so far that's
literally I could never see that on my
Xbox so far I can never see that tick
tocks fan tick tocks just doing up I
need to Bourbon Shire
I'd eat a bow and Shire
that is jokes
a list of his lies he wrote down on his
notes so he didn't change his stories
and get caught out
okay
oh yeah
what lies have I told I need to rehearse
the whole thing that's that is a
calculated prick
nudes of the girl they told me not to
worry oh of course
who is this [ __ ]
why are you asking me stupid questions
Sarah oh my God respect me respect
embarrassing yourself respect Sarah
wow you think I would smash Sarah these
times he's got news
[Music]
these things
that's the face he makes when he's in
there yeah yeah screenshots from
FaceTime Amazon
[Music]
my ex had a foot fetish he had vids of
him zooming in on his sister's feet as
she was talking to him
his sister's feet
bro that's a fetish because if you can
involve family yeah that's a fetish
stuff like that scared stuff like that
specifically scares me because I don't
know you anymore
it's fat and you're zoom in your your
fans as your sister's feet I am with
someone that I don't know facts bro
facts and that's terrifying because you
could just kill me tomorrow and just
keep my feet yeah drop my feet off just
keep it in a job you're gonna keep my
feet in the jar I know you are you're
gonna preserve the thing because that's
what you like
that's what you're about
I have to bounce
oh because that's what you like it is
that's what you like so I have to bounce
I'm sorry but I have to bounce
come on
sorry
maybe laugh my boyfriend said to another
ghost
foreign
[Music]
my boyfriend said to another girl that I
was his sister
don't look at me like that
oh don't even
[Laughter]
ah let's move on
let's move on let's move on let's move
on oh a pros and cons list about me
where's his friends
do not run [ __ ] that's yeah yeah very
[ __ ] Peak
pros and cons pros and cons list about
me the oh those cons must have shook her
to the court to the Cobra tits are
lopsided
time
craziest thing she found on my phone I
was sleeping with her brother
prayer on prayer
no that was a girl that said that
I was sorry I was sleeping with his
brother
no her brother so it was huh what are
you saying to me who's that craziest
thing she found on my phone I was
sleeping with her brother
so it's two female so I'm a girl that
sent this in just not her friend yeah oh
I was a couple no okay cool cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool wow
invoice for breast milk that he bought
on the internet no I I didn't know that
was a I think that's impossible bro to
be fair anything's possible but I don't
know where you searched for these things
that's that's Incognito yeah yeah that's
right
you can't even put it on Google that's a
duckduck go thing
let's attack that guy
how much for breast milk fam
I'm trying to lose breast milk exactly
who's breast milk I'm just clogged he's
literally
yeah that's a black market yeah stop
stop stop stop stop stop saying again
I'm with someone that I don't know and I
have to leave immediately my whole life
is a Fallout what does he want to do
with it James breast the milk literally
literally
that's the wildest one yeah that's
horrible
my ex sending full body nudes to an old
man for 5K a month
I would a guy said that
so it's a girl said that about her guy
that's why I said I would you wouldn't
not now I wouldn't
yeah you would
I wouldn't
have to do anything else you'd have to
chat to him
you have to do anything for 60 bags a
year you just have to go to your
Forefront of fall new to an old man yeah
just once a day just you're naked anyway
once a day isn't that what I said
I don't know but I said a month bun me
for 5K yeah once a day you didn't say
anything it just said man sends uh my
extended full news to an old man for 5K
a month you okay bro I'm sending you
facts right now
if I wake up
wake up to him I'd have to do
it today I've got a full body mirror
outside my bathroom door
take my boxes off I'll walk in I'm
walking to the bathroom
and just straight but I don't pose I
don't art I don't do anything leg sturdy
but maybe one of these no
for five bags a month no bro just that I
don't need it though sir it's not about
needing I know but it's tax-free of
course there's going to be tax rips nah
bro five bags a month
you don't even have to you don't even
see his response
I think that'll be that'll be worse I
don't even know if that would be worse
but
I think it would be worse not seeing his
response oh I promise you've seen his
responsibly worse
seeing what he wants to do to you that's
worse I'm just send him to pick either
way I'm not doing it so yes I swear 10
bags a month he would
show me the 10 first and maybe we'll
talk [ __ ] should be I need to see the
code five right I know you would that's
calm though I don't know I won't do it
why I just don't need to bro yeah I know
you don't fair enough but you know you
know what I'm actually gonna drop it
fair enough don't you you don't need I
don't need to I don't know I don't need
to I don't know what to say
videos okay sorry back to it worst thing
you found on someone has a phone part
two videos of his sorry videos of his
two gender reveals with two different
women that weren't me
man is doing gender reveals
plural me
how is he keeping this Trifecta together
oh he must be pulling out his hairs to
balance everything it's not worth it
really isn't it all sometimes and it's
just stupid
they get lost in it and there's no way
out yeah yeah they actually get it's
hard to come out yeah they find
themselves
[Applause]
because girl number three I.E Hershey's
in her head they're in a relationship
100. and she has no reason to believe
otherwise 100 that he's deep into it 100
each time she's got two Utes on the way
yeah or probably here at the moment
literally and the ways they're not
gender reveals that she sees that and
thinks raw he's actually doing up happy
family happy family
in his head he's thinking I don't want
to be here I don't want you a I don't
want you B I don't want the smoke I
don't want to smoke I just want to leave
it in and for nothing else to happen and
now I'm in these situations they're
threatening me on social media if I
don't comply they want the money up
front like it's just not worth it I have
to show up to the general reveal because
otherwise the family is going to be at
my doorstep facts because I tried to say
I didn't want to do a general reveal
she's called me a piece of [ __ ] then I
said I'm not coming to the gender reveal
now she's saying her dad is going to
come to my yard all this thing so now
I'm at the general reveal and he's just
there just
oh it's yellow I mean yellow pink oh
it's pink oh it's blue oh thumbs up
thumbs up can I go are we done okay can
I go now boom safe Deuces back to I'm
going back tomorrow I'm going back to my
real wide [ __ ] both of you oh that's
jokes my mum and my sister conspiring to
take money from me in totally they took
five hundred dollars
is that it we do not conspiracy for 500.
wow so old messages on his WhatsApp
begging to date girls oh
please please I need it back the last
one an album named after me full of
pictures of me sleeping
sleeping
that's creepy bro
creepy stuff
you've not said a word creepy stuff bro
sleeping an album a whole album A whole
album sweet dreams
sweet sweet dream Sarah XOXO dreams bro
that's terrified yeah this is
this is a perfect part too to why you
shouldn't go through people's phones
factual factual it's just worth not do
it you don't want to cause yourself that
kind of Heartache it's not worth it and
the information you wanted to find out
trust me you don't want to find out
because it's going to make your week
month year terrible
terrible
facts facts let's just not do it stay in
your lane let's literally just not study
and just stay happy
um poor man that was banging awesome
guys so welcome back yeah episode 227 I
believe I think so before we go any
further guys please please just pause
the episode right here head on over to
patreon.com
only gonna cost you three pound a month
10p a day run the P2 sng and catch up on
three years worth of bonus content bonus
episodes where we get into the
nitty-gritty you see
besides of us you may not have seen on
these episodes or if you just like to
binge head on over there and binge on
top of that guys you get an episode
every single Thursday without fail perks
guys if you are listening on a podcast
app audio please leave us a nice review
five stars are preferable but say
whatever you want to say with your chest
and finally guys if you're watching us
on YouTube please subscribe to the
channel like the video if you liked the
video and as always chirps a thing in
the comments and become a certified cult
baby yes sir right guys without any
further Ado my ombre Fire Lord Flags is
going to hit us with the fun fact of the
day please
do your thing so guys the fun fact of
the day single lad who has a single lad
who has never had a girlfriend decides
to take out a billboard in search for
love
the course I think I saw this I didn't
read it but I saw the little date me
please yes
oh it's Peak
the course of true love never did run
smooth but for one single guy not even
hinged Tinder or any other day in any
other online dating app has managed to
help him find a suitable girlfriend
Ed Chapman from Leeds explain how upon
reaching the age of 23 he feels like
he's region an age where he should be he
should have been on at least one day
before I've never been on a date that's
got wrenching
however rather than giving up on finding
love completely Ed decided to get
creative Ed revealed that he's been
single for all his 23 years but is now
ready to find someone to hopefully be in
a relationship with
I tried some this is him talking I have
tried some day in apps but it didn't go
well for me at all
instead of moving around listening to
sad music e and ice cream and Spoon and
his dog and spooning his dog to sleep
and yes there's a chance I'm speaking
from personal experience
dogs to sleep wow and decided
foreign
decided to think outside the box and
reach out to potent two potential
girlfriends via something they did they
definitely couldn't ignore a giant
billboard with his face and email on it
the 23 year old explained how lots of
women found the billboard funny which
was one of the aims of it to reflect his
personality edsense has been speaking to
four women who are all Keen to go on
dates with him because they think he's
got that billboard money and then yeah
that's him with the billboard saying
dami
um what would you do
if you know me I've never been on a date
I've never had a thing I I struggle in
clubs
I struggling I can see that all you man
clean up I'm just them in the corner two
stepping to myself struggling because
I'm the partest friend yeah yeah I'm
struggling bro I go out it's just no
love
just no love and I'm I don't even tell
you man I'm doing this
you just see we're backing you this is
uni times or whatever of course we're
back in like cough yeah yeah you just
see a massive billboard oh it's
embarrassing of myself holding up a pair
of a pair of roses
roses and I'm like date me please here's
my email address please email everyone
at this point anyone and I'll change the
email address like food had needs love
at hotmail.com
I'm buying you escorts
let's start knocking these out and get
your confidence up
because this is appalling Behavior
he's it's it's dread because he's not
the most handsome guy like
I'm just gonna say he's definitely like
he's not the most handsome guy he's
socially awkward he's probably funny in
a weird way like in a Yu-Gi-Oh way
Yugio way what does that even mean
everyone knows what it means what does
that even mean funny in a Dungeons and
Dragons kind of way
um [ __ ] that's me and me so yeah I don't
know man I
I think if I saw you doing that one part
of me would be like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you the other part of me like
you know what
fair play because I've been drapes new
to clubs yeah and it's not working I set
up your Tinder profile myself it's not
working bro no Tinder
haven't said anything must match the
works Bros
order them swipe and know that everyone
said No so at this point unless I've got
a better answer for you I have to let
you do your thing
but I'll be so heartbroken that it's
it's we've got here I'll be so
heartbroken we've got here and I know
you wouldn't accept the escorts either
because he was lucky I want real love
Yeah I want a real I want a connection
yeah I don't just want to smash yeah I
want to get to know you and your parents
that's what I want oh that was break
that's what I need I could but I this
I'm telling you this would have to be
the last draw otherwise it's a like
suicide pact because
if this doesn't work yeah I physically
wouldn't be able to stand the hike it
would put me through
let's see what side yeah we'd have to
die together because I couldn't watch
you that's true that's money as well
you've been saving and you invested
money into a billboard for love Yeah and
you've been chatting to 40 you can never
tell me James I'm not gonna lie since
the billboard I've been chatting to four
things I'll be like shut your dirty
little mouth sweat out you're like yeah
I think they're down I think they said
they're all Keen to link say less that's
part of it and then next day while Guan
I don't know I'm texting they're just
not replying bro I've texted all four of
them all from the times of the day
they've all seen it and they're not
replying not James they're not replying
it's normal is this normal
I'm coming to your advice is this normal
is this no I'm coming to you for advice
James is this normal because you clean
up I see what you do in the clubs is
this normal
I liked your face and say yes because
it's been around three to four hours
obviously I know that they could have
been drunk from last night blah blah but
yet no one's really replying to me bro
and I've it's not like I'm being too
much I'm just texting them like good
morning darling what's your day saying
blah blah blah just different nice
little sweet things a couple X's there a
couple O's there none of them are
replying James but yesterday they were
on it show me their faces now because
we're gonna we're gonna do stuff
because
you can't be treated like this bro you
don't [ __ ] deserve it
I'm not gonna sit here I'm just not
gonna sit here and see you just get
abused like yeah yeah this is not fair
it's not funny
take the billboard down yeah first of
all first of all let's get that
billboard down because of piss take
these men are treating you like a joke
bro
it's the only way I could find love like
the apps weren't working for me bro you
know I'm socially awkward you know I
can't move together so I need them to
move to me
you know
fine for you had love gmail.com or
whatever I said they're monkeying you
before you had finds love if you had
needs love marking you off it's all a
joke to them they're probably living the
same flat they can't bro different
locations but it's not different
locations they're playing different
locations they're playing you I've been
talking the maddest team I'm not even
talking to them on WhatsApp I'm talking
to them via email I know you are I'm
talking because they're a YouTuber email
bro you don't even know what they look
like I'm talking to the via email bro
let's just end it let's just come with
me let's just end it all right now I'll
just do that for you let's just jump
let's just jump bro and it all ends all
of this oh the pain stops now let's leap
because I can't see this anymore
bro I I I definitely told you I think
I've told the story on here before
like that used to be my but I'm not even
gonna bait his name on here that used to
be my boy in sixth form okay couldn't
clean up for anything for love no money
could not get a pawn bruh and we were at
a party one time and he was just like
he's a white brother skinny short white
brother at the time and I said Jazz I
just want to hold a wine all right yeah
yeah I did tell you sorry
and I was like [ __ ] we're gonna get you
away we're gonna give you a [ __ ] wine
bro let's go I remember when you I
remember the story vividly because I
remember the first time you told this
story I imagined it was me and you and
we were in club live the old Club live
for some reason my head went there
because I know the story but I remember
him looking up to his puppy dog I said I
just want to hold a wine like I've never
even danced with a girl and I was like
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] that we're going yeah
you're gonna hold a wine now bro
tonight's not nice get a beer you little
white brother get beer get a Budweiser
and watch me work and I don't even I
will do anything for you for you yeah
I'll give them money if I have yeah
found first thing I went up to was like
a mutual her name was Hannah and I was
like please wine him just for a minute
she was like in fact she was like no
[ __ ] you I literally [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you went into the next team yeah
and that was the one where I was like
please wine him and she was like I'm not
whining him but I want you and I was
like
you [ __ ]
you sexy little bit internal conflict
yeah I'll be back in five
and I was like God damn it and then he
looked over like oh no what's his name
is yes no and I was like bro these hoes
are just useless anyway yeah
they were down but I genuinely don't
think they're for you they're Butters
bro we need to leave here and find real
pristine things yeah because these hoes
are just horrible
wait for like two tracks
I'll be back I need a bashment and a
slow jam I'm just gonna say my goodbyes
yeah
I'm just gonna do one last lap to make
sure
it's disgusting that's the combination
ah frontal as well jeans were tight yeah
it was crazy yeah what's up guys time to
pay some bills real quick and you know
it is Halloween season now guys Michael
Myers sure is scary but the last thing
you need is to be hairy this Halloween
facts you heard it first luckily our
friends at manscape launched their
fourth generation performance package to
make sure your pumpkins get the ultimate
carving experience let's go go with the
word play turn your bite-sized tree into
a king-sized Camp oh let's bite size
three
rotted come on turn that trick to a
treat guys along with six million men
worldwide who trust manscape by going to
manscape.com using the code sng
got 20 off and free shipping guys make
the right call this spooky season is
trick or trim let's get back to the
episode let's yeah yeah that that oh
[ __ ] I remember that night but me so
much for him tough and I was like this
is some [ __ ] man this is not fair my
name shouldn't have to go through this
no we should have to go for that bro man
I'm going for it gotta go for it like
yeah they do oh God gotta go through it
as well man
um be happy with what you got kind of
thing man yeah because I remember
there's
yeah that
will say same thing to me like my
bridges got a crush daddy daddy
and I'm like yeah yeah who is it see her
and you want to be like are you taking
the piss like you clearly don't rape me
as a friend because how the [ __ ] do you
think he could pair me with that
do you know what I mean though and you
know the maddest you know the P kissed
ones you know the kissed ones
the biggest ones are let me speak bro
sorry
the biggest ones are when women come up
to you and say oh my brethren likes you
and you just like
first of all you're banging yeah
so I'm hoping your friend is equally or
just around the same level it's actually
you and your shot
I'm hoping the bridge is actually you
you're on a third person thing yeah this
is all a weird third person thing
because your brethren is you yeah they
say your bread oh my bridging is feeling
you
come on bro come on bro like why would
you even do that and it's one of those
ones as well it's like
as a man when you politely and humbly
reject them it's like
I'm the prick oh bro if you're like no
thanks they're like wow like she's
gorgeous like you would be lucky
you're an [ __ ] is what you are you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] because you know she's
not gorgeous that's why you came over
facts that's why she stood in the corner
because she's got no confidence so you
as the penguan have to come up to me gas
me up like say you're moving to me yeah
she sees me smiling because I'm smiling
at her
horrible situation and it's not my fault
I should be allowed to reject anyone
yeah same way you rejects a man on a
daily basis 100 if I'm rejecting your
friend that doesn't make me an [ __ ]
you're a prick for even thinking I would
like your friends
facts well it's so that they're always
banging unbelievably back and the friend
is just not it's always it's not even
the second paying his friend it's the
worst one it's just not cutting it and
it's not fair for you to put me in that
situation it isn't fair it's not fair
[ __ ] sake man that's so funny I just
want to lips you yeah like I want to see
you I don't want a lips your friend
literally and then you don't want to
feel like a prick because you want to
just move to her facts and you're like
how do I yeah
it's Darkness yeah yes I can't have you
and I definitely don't want your friend
and they're just pissed off now all the
girls hate me yeah all the girls hate me
and I can't even move to anyone else in
here because if you see it you're gonna
think I'm a bigger waste yeah relax
facts facts I didn't ask for this I
genuinely didn't ask for it so yeah um
females there is no entitlement when you
move to a guy oh because you think this
is
if I did it if I went to a girl I was
like my bedroom likes you she'd be like
uh grow up
if I did that they'd be like wow
shut up exactly why do you think you're
so nice
um anyway I've got a try not to laugh oh
yeah I forgot about that hit me this is
what gone I was gonna say this is
the second time you've done it by
yourself right second time I've done it
by myself
um oh maybe third actually third yeah
I'm actually gonna not laugh today are
they dark humor so I've done a mixture
this time
some of them are dark humor and uh some
of them are obviously dad jokes yeah
cool daddy jokes daddy jokes daddy jokes
say this I'm not gonna laugh you're not
gonna laugh right
all right
guys try not to laugh at home as well
what do you call a fish wearing a bow
tie
what do you call a fish wearing a bow
tie
I don't know
sophisticated
[Laughter]
that was a good one sophisticated that's
funny that was a good one
how do you find Will Smith in the snow
no idea
Follow The Fresh Prince
that's actually a very good joke
that's actually a very good job fair
[ __ ] play Oh follow the freshness
that's actually a really good joke sick
[ __ ] that's a really good joke right
damn I'm vex
how many tickles does it take to make an
octopus laugh
don't say articles or octacles how many
tentacles
why I don't even know why I didn't even
think of that yeah yeah
eight tickles
um okay slightly darker mm-hmm what do
you call a cheap circumcision
oh I've seen that one I rip off I've
seen that one before it's ripoff that's
Butters bro that must be painful okay
slightly darker
what do you get when you mix human DNA
and goat DNA
human DNA and goat DNA I don't know
kicked out of the zoo
[Laughter]
kicked out of the zoo fair fair [ __ ]
place those jokes
all right ready
I went to see a doctor about my rash
he said I was a sight for psoriasis
I think I've seen that one before
[ __ ] that one caught me a sight for
psoriasis
oh God right
you'll probably laugh at this one
because you're a piece of [ __ ] oh my God
what's the difference between me and
cancer
between human cancer what was the
difference between me and cancer what's
the difference my dad didn't beat cancer
I've seen that one bro that's dark it's
dark on multiple
everyone held a bang
[ __ ] my dad didn't beat cancer fam okay
last one yeah I'll never forget my
grandma's last words
what
what are you gonna do with that hammer
I've seen that one as well all right bet
all right that was try not to laugh it's
tough now because you would have seen
Ben you would have seen bad the
sophisticated was jokes The Fresh Prince
The Fresh Prince was a joke James
Follow The Fresh Prince wow that's
comedy that's banging that's comedy oh
and I think I love that another one but
fair play Yeah Yeah The Fresh Prince
one's got me the Fresh Prince one caught
me
that's made me happy that's actually
made me happy I'm a dude am I the
[ __ ] but
am I the uh so we will decide am I the
[ __ ] let's just find out and right
this one's
this one's I don't even know if there's
an [ __ ] thing but it's like a
just a bit of a yum yum
it's a bit of yum yum you'll see you'll
see you'll see yourself right am I the
[ __ ] for wanting to sleep with my
daughter's teacher
I mean off the cuff probably not no bro
my daughter's tea I don't know but he
also went to sleep with my daughter's
teacher
my youngest daughter started a new
school
um started a new school when she was in
year three and she had a male teacher
let's call him Mr C my daughter had Mr C
for around three months before she was
due to move into year four the whole
time she was in year four Mr C had to
come to the same part of the school to
collect his class of children
he would
um and every time he would he would make
strong eye contact with me
to the point where my oldest daughter
made a comment on how she noticed Mr C
was making eye contact kids noticed
everything bro yeah
now we're in year five and he no longer
comes to the same part of the school due
to being moved to a different year group
so me and Mr C don't see each other that
much
the other day I had to go to the school
office to see if anyone had handed him
my daughter's school jumper
as we were talking uh to the office lady
Mr C walked in and heard what we were
there for
just as me and my daughter were about to
leave he called my daughter's name and
asked if she remembered where she last
had it he then turned to me to tell me
he's going to do everything in his power
to get the jump and jumper back to her
my guy
the sexual tension between us is mad I
just want to bang him whenever I see him
he's so sexy
I don't know how to go about making him
know I want him to she'd even ask if
she's the [ __ ]
just at the beginning she just carried
on carried on is that it that's
no I don't know how to let she'd even
say should I shouldn't I said no the
thing is when you first said the
original
um header I assumed the parent was a man
and the teacher that's what I assumed
and I don't know why as soon as you said
my daughter and let's call him as the
exos finger this is sexy this is sexy
because the other way around just out
obviously it just seems a lot more
sexier for me like I was seeing myself
out Mr C I'm Mr C right I'm Mr X 100 and
I'm like
oh there's banging mums making eye
contact with me it's a wrap I'm telling
you now
it's a wrap because I can't concentrate
throughout nine to three no no no no I'm
waiting till 3 15 so I can see your mum
that's why that's why I'm coming to
school Monday to Friday Rags cause I
want to see your mum at the end of
school
those parents evenings the tench I I
wouldn't James I promise you I wouldn't
break eye contact oh I know you wouldn't
I promise you I know you would have
swallow spit and crannies crumble I love
it yeah yeah it looks like your daughter
might need some personal tutoring
fat sir she might need some personal
treat her in fact she needs a lot of
at-home attention
facts and I'm available I'm literally
available I'm available any weekend it's
necessary
I'm available and I can come around as
many times as I need to you just until
we get the job done
Madam Madam save us lessons on me
just tell me when just tell me when and
tell me where hey tell me when to come
and where
hey hey hey yeah I'd lose it yeah what
do you think about that what do you
think what do you say because I I don't
have the confidence for that because my
lip will be equivalent huh
[Laughter]
it's just a suggestion or find someone
else already like Gray's a fight anyway
he doesn't even need it
oh my goodness plus I'm married so [ __ ]
off yeah I forget yeah anyway
um time's up
fine that's too sexy
um is she the ass up she's not even
given much
um
first of all it's not even an am I the
[ __ ] so let's confront this yeah
first of all you're not even asking if
you're the answer goes first of all it's
not even your daughter's teacher anymore
uh and secondly like I don't really
understand the ramifications of doing it
like do you have a husband yeah yeah is
he married what what he did sleep with
him what would make you an [ __ ] I
don't really understand the fact that
his partner from the fact that maybe she
might wake up and see just Mr C just in
the kitchen eating cereal yeah that
might piss her off yeah that would
traumatize her 100 that would traumatize
me yeah definitely yeah I would say only
do it if you're just gonna bang him and
leave it yeah don't form a relationship
with a teacher from your daughter's
school that's butter I mean it's it's
that's going to be tough to do like If
She Bangs him once or vice versa if they
bang once it'll be hard especially if
the sexual tension matches the Sexual
Energy oh God it will be hard to stop
because because I'm at the school five
days a week every week for 52 weeks yeah
you know what I mean yeah yeah apart
from holidays or whatever but I'm
they're all I'm gonna see him he's gonna
see percentage so it will be hard to not
bang him
oh sorry it'll be hard to bang him and
then not
and then try and stop if for example
even if it was good it would be hard to
stop
um if you're trying to remove like the
daughter situation out of business or so
um I don't really see how you can start
and stop and like James said I don't
really know what the ramifications are
you've not said you're married or
engaged or
um if he's single or if he's not it's
just the fact that he's a school teacher
and your daughter happens to go to that
school and that's it and the other
ramification is your older daughter has
seen the eye contact that you guys yeah
miss it looks like Mr C's trying to clap
cheeks and yeah
uh I couldn't be the parent
I couldn't be a father of two daughters
taking them to school and I'm seeing a
banging teacher across the across the
hall and she's just given me the eyes
James and I'm not breaking icons I'm not
blinked and I shouldn't run I'm my
youngest my older daughter just pulls on
my child's like Daddy why is she looking
at me why is she staring at me why is
she staring at you like that
I'll be like if I looked down
I'll look down so angry like right first
of all why are you ruining the whole
thing I said why are you so smart like
why are you clocking this fam yeah to be
fair you could never be a single dad of
two daughters the moms would try and
suck you off
it would be long it would be long I'll
be a mama three and four yeah yeah yeah
100 single dad two daughters yeah
they'll be buff as well yeah of course
of course I already know and you're
walking them to school every day every
day yeah bro the moms the teachers
everyone's trying to slop
it couldn't run it couldn't you my gas
I would be gas it would be it would be a
good way to start the day because
no one wants to wake up that early
anyway but obviously doing the school
run blah blah it'll be a good way to
start today
endorphins and then you're you're gassed
about little things like if your plaque
looks extra nice in her hair today these
hoes won't be able to control themselves
today
oh my God
where did you learn to do her hair
but you have to you have to make the
effort you know what I mean you have to
you have to wake up early you have to
get on YouTube learn how to do these
hairs because they they don't have their
mum there yeah oh they're crazy it's
just me they would create the big house
because I make bread I'm all alone all
alone when these kids are at school I'm
all alone [ __ ] it's tough it's boring
out here it is boring I get I get a lot
of pen up energy frustration trying to
release that yeah I'm trying to release
that are you trying to swallow yeah I'm
trying to release her no one's there to
oh anyway anyway see you at 3 30.
see ya do you think
the nature
I would love to [ __ ] ahead teacher
really like a banging head no I'm like a
teacher's assistant kind of guy no no I
would love to [ __ ] them all I don't I
don't care if they're banging up these
are all hypothetical obviously yeah
obviously
I wouldn't care what you teach and what
what hierarchy what but I would love to
bag ahead to each other that's in my
office Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah rulers are out your glasses
and she's got a spinning globe in there
just cause yeah yeah yeah that's jokes
Christ almighty um did we even answer
the question uh I don't think there's a
question to be answered just do what you
want yeah because it's boring there were
no ramifications you've not suggested
that there would be any ramifications so
yeah just [ __ ] him man
I guess I'm assuming there must be a
ramification hence whatever else she's
asking about no just [ __ ] I guess
literally it was a good um good scenario
good segue oh yeah banging
um right
I've got a thread oh yeah I've got a
little thread I like him when you have
threads I don't have
this is to be fair this is the one you
when you said oh there was one I just
don't think it would work I bet this is
the one hmm okay what was that one the
thing is I can't remember what the um
heading was but I just remember it was
loads of
was very conversational okay so it
couldn't translate this one okay
okay so this is something that uh
someone sent me
um from the shade room it's actually
funny you must have seen it I think
we've got sent in loads okay so
um
how do you tell someone that their
breath stinks in Shakespeare language
have you seen this one things I've seen
I saw I saw that and I think I saw one
reply and that was it oh okay so yes
I'm gonna need to wet my palette because
I need to articulate these perfect I've
seen one I've seen one yeah yeah about
Karma boys yes yes yes gang right how do
you tell someone that their breath
stinks in Shakespeare language yeah
right
alas
what
already alas yeah why does the pungency
of thou breath inflict such a villainous
blow of which is offensive to thine
nostrils
fam
this one yeah truly I have suffered the
slings and arrows of Misfortune by the
stench that dwelleth in the deepest pits
of thy gums oh my God pause
eloquent bars fam the hounds of Hades
hath parked before thee
guarding each breath and syllable
syllable
jokes brought the hounds of Hades Farm
yeah these men are they went for it yeah
they went for it yeah yeah yeah yeah
is thus a dagger of air which I
is thus a dagger of air which I seen
thrown before me with such Force towards
my nose
bro this is such House of dragon [ __ ]
bro this one's sweet me
thou breath fights freshness as much as
thine own enemy
I really spoken to like that James
I couldn't be spoken to like that thou
Breath by its freshness as much as thine
own enemy
funny
man said your breath fights the fresh
like I fight the Ops
thank you
nah funny
right
surely thou Hast not brusheth thy teeth
upon the rising of the sun on this day
flee from my presence
for thy stench can and nostrils no
longer continue to Bear flee from my
presence
I'm using that bar bro I'm using that
bar big man Flee for my presence
listen to me bro I couldn't be spoken to
like that James flee from my presence
from my presence bro your breath is
bumping
please
bro yo Hawk what death lies between Thou
Art tongue I cannot bear to breathe
depart from me
depart from me yo
oh God why has Thou breathist forsaken
thee
right
my dear beloved thou breath has betrayed
thee in the most wicked of ways death
becometh all who encountereth a simple
with doth I understand my heart weepeth
much wow that one was a lot man did a
young son or son
Mighty Soldier thou beareth the breath
of a thousand dragons
I was waiting for him to say dragons
fight the alas fam the Alas and flee
from my presence flee from my presence
that's the end of it there flee from my
presence bar I'm using that I promise
you I'm using I couldn't stomach it flee
from my press run I said run Flee for my
presence cause your breath is pumping
thank you
found that oh that's a depart depart
from me depart from me
yo that says
Twitter is the best place it is
the best place funniest app going bro
it's the funniest app people are two
jokes man the two creatives unbearable
it's so good unbearable [ __ ] you know
right guys a little bit of a shorter one
today
um but yeah I really enjoyed that so
thank you for [ __ ] with us today
as always guys head on over to
patreon.com
gigs to get the bonus episode on
Thursday and as always guys love love
gang gang gang
[Music]